this'll be great
I feel like I'm gonna pull my that is
close how do I have no friends that
would ever touch me Oh go Matt I didn't
CrossFit how'd you get flexstretch and
stuff
my mom tried to sign me up for an eighth
grade class but I refused I've seen lots
of women do it before so I don't think
it's gonna be a big problem for me we're
just kind of sleeping right all right
how are you dan I'm Emily David nice to
meet you okay I'll have you take off
your shoes and socks put them back on
later don't worry
yeah it's part of like the process No
okay so let's go ahead and start in
Tadasana standing Mountain Pose
well spread the toes suspend your energy
down good exhale forward fold
lead with the heart come on all the way
down is that as far as you can go this
is as far as I can go oh how I live and
now we'll do Breath of Fire so this is a
rapid inhale exhale through the nose
beautiful that's it we're done
no no you you've got the first pose okay
so coming into cat and cow pose do you
say cat and cow cat and cow Durga go
dropping the belly lifting the tail
we're gonna bend the left knee and grab
the foot just grab it right hand reaches
overhead yeah and stay with the breath
keep breathing in and out through the
nose right arm reaches up ready for the
next move in that sequence okay so we're
gonna start with Eagle pose cross the
right thigh over the left and wrap the
foot behind the left calf you know me
just wrap it around and then cross the
arms hips a little lower where's your
Drishti okay that was a rare minute no
giving up okay and then we'll sit toward
a squat like chair pose that's easy and
then we're gonna bring the hands to the
floor resting on me and hit on the
elbows so what then just kick the feet
apart
so give me resting on the elbows
okay try pretty sure this breakdancing
you're doing great
are you breathing no so this bowl is
made of quartz crystal on has healing
energy so just close your eyes find a
meditative place
Oh
I wish I took the class in a three
namaste
wait what namaste jeez
Yoga is really hard this was a little
more difficult than I thought I thought
the boat was sweet people who say that
yoga is in a workout are totally wrong
this mat is the real deal okay I just
can't take that
do you sell yes okay now this day thanks
for the very last loss it's awesome